Hello, everyone. This is Anne with Connors Clinic, and today we're going to talk about B vitamins.
B vitamins are a key player in maintaining optimal health and keeping you energized.
They catalyze numerous metabolic reactions throughout the body by acting as coal enzymes for
the release of energy. And the energy that is released with the assistance of B vitamins is called ATP.
ATP is what our cells use, again, as energy to perform all of their complicated functions.
B vitamins are made up of eight different vitamins that are water-soluble, and this means that
they're excreted from the body on a daily basis, and so they must be replenished. How do we
replenish our B vitamins? Well, we get them from the variety of different fruits and vegetables that
we eat, from the foods that we eat, and we also can produce them through our gut microbiome.
So if you're not eating a healthy Whole Foods diet, or if you have gut dysbiosis, chances are
you're not getting adequate B vitamins. And here's just kind of a list of some of the functions
that B vitamins are involved in helping to regulate the thyroid, helping support the immune system,
protecting the heart and blood vessels, reducing the risk of developing cataracts.
B vitamins help support healthy hair skin and nails, and they help regulate stress and mood.
So it's one of the supplements, a B vitamins supplement, that we use a lot here at Conor's
Clinic as one of the pieces that are kind of a foundational piece to helping support people who
are coming to us with a myriad of different symptoms. We'll assess the B vitamins, make sure they're
getting them through their diet, and sometimes we do need to take the next step and really add some
support with a supplement. When we're looking at the genetic pathways, here are a few of the pathways
that we look at. And it's kind of hard to see, but you can see here in some of these little red,
or I mean, excuse me, green, fine print here. We see tons of B vitamins listed. These are
co-factors to, again, get all of these reactions to occur. So definitely there is a genetic component.
Maybe if you have a defect on a specific gene, something's not quite working properly, but also
if you don't have enough B vitamins to help these reactions to occur, you potentially are going to
have some ill health. The supplement that, again, that we use here at Conor's Clinic is called
B specific. Naturally, it's a naturally sourced vitamin B vitamin. It does not have the B 12,
and B 12 is really something that we like to look at the person as an individual and make a
recommendation based on that specific person. We have methylated versions or non-methylated versions,
and depending on whether or not you're cancer patient, if you have genetic variants or different
symptoms, we'll make a different recommendation on the type of B 12 that you should use. If you're
interested in learning more about these B vitamin supplements that we offer, you can check them out on
minewebstore at shop.conorsclinic.com. Thank you. Have a great day.